but let's turn now to Bangladesh a court
is due to deliver its verdict on the
case of two prominent human rights
activists they faced 10 years in prison
after publishing a report a decade ago
that accused security forces of
extrajudicial killings targeting
protesters al-shazira's tanvirachodri is
covering the story for us and you're
joining us from Dhaka tanvir tell us
more about this trial because we're
talking about the leader of what was one
of the most prominent human rights
groups in Bangladesh
absolutely uh Mr adilu Rahman Khan and
the director Mr nasruddin Elan that both
charge and could possibly face between
seven to ten years in prison now what
they're accused of is a story in 2013
when Bangladesh was going through a lot
of political unrest the government
Security Forces cracked down on a
madrasa based islamist platform
organization that had a huge rally in
beginning of May first week of May in
the capital city between 400 to 500 000
people were there early morning this
Crackdown took place what the human
rights organization did is published a
report of the number of people of
casualties after a week it happened and
also some images which the government
said were distorted and tempered image
they didn't agree with the number the
government said only 11 people were
killed with the human rights
organization said at least 61 people
were killed which is very much Corollary
by the international U.S human rights
organization which had 58 people killed
so the verdict is going to be out
anytime soon the judge is hearing of the
case story background uh telling the
case people who are dead at least 50
people are present even some journalists
are present there so uh and also during
that period right before the 2014
election there was a lot of violent
hundreds of people were injured a number
of at least hundreds of people were
killed during those periods so odika has
been pursuing that as well as
extrajudicial killing rights violation
enforce disappearing so they've been in
the bad eye of the government and hence
this information communication act 2006
that being used to charge them and today
we're gonna know the final verdict so in
tenure there are key elections around
the corner in Bangladesh as well as
regular protests in the run-up to those
elections what message does this trial
send
yes I mean if the verdict finds them
guilty it will send out a chilling
message to the rest of the Civil Society
human rights organization as well as the
media in general because the government
has come under criticism not only
locally but internationally for cracking
down on media civil society and human
rights organization using what is new
the Cyber Security Act and even with
defamation laws on fabricated stories
made up by somebody and then they'll say
that you you could be arrested without
warrant some amendments been made in
this new Amendment but if this verdict
is handed out to them they're found
guilty this absolutely could have a
chilling effect on the Civil Society as
I say
and the rights organization in
Bangladesh ahead of the election all
right tambia children is just before 2
30 PM local time in Dhaka as soon as you
get a verdict you will let us know of
any developments thank you very much
tenvir